I feel like this is a theory,
you guys probably like there's like people to tell you how you feel about
something for, they say, um, Hey, you'll like this. It's like,
we'll decide to have to,
but is that a lot of the people that didn't grow up?
A lot of the people that set the rules of New York ethnic
non-identification grew up subconsciously in their mind.
They want everybody to be the same so that they can recreate the bland,
suburban strip mall that they grew up in. Right.
So they had subconsciously doing it too. They're like, no,
we want everybody the same because that's how we grew up.
So that means that's good. Right. Instead of going, I left there for a reason.
That's interesting. I never thought about it that way.
They probably have no choice. Now you're saying it's like a subconscious thing.
Cause that's how, that's what they know. That's how they're conditioned.
They think they're being,
they actually being 10 times more racist than anyone could ever be by not
identifying peoples. You know what I'm I always used to say celebrate diversity.
Don't put it out. People are different, you know? And so there,
you know what they mean?
It's just so obvious to me that there's something off with it.
Yeah. Park slope is European. All right. it.
My brothers. No I'm saying, I like that.
I like how the kids in my puppy is European. I liked that.
Yeah. That's top level. Yeah. Yeah, because that's.
My brother said a half the kids in the class, they're from France.
They moved in and moved back after a year. They stay like all his,
his daughter's friends in like sixth grade. I mean with seven,
eight year old kids, first grade, whatever it is, um, very advanced six. And um,
yeah, they're all from like different countries. Spain, France. Hey,
what are we losing?
No, it was just reading about the trade. I mean the guy's like, no,
I was just reading. I was way too comfortable. You listen to that.
I'm in the middle of trying to describe my brother's poor kid.
Trying to go to school, a friend to leave after a year.
[inaudible] On Instagram have been sober for how many years now?
I don't talk about that. Oh, sorry. Yeah. I mean, yeah.
A long time, a long time does that have to do with it?
I don't know because you name it all the bars, but you don't drink. I know,
but this was back when I was like young.
Oh, and your boss don't exist anymore. Yeah.
I remember we went into that bar in Dublin that the cheese sandwiches.
And you said to me, you said you were like, you were like, Hey, let's go.
And I was like, all right, we go. And then you're like,
if I would've stayed in there another five minutes,
I would have been dead in six months
because it was bringing back memories because you said it looked like a bar in
park slope.
You know? It's so true. Yeah. Only time. I mean, I quit drink in
1983. I was born in 84. Say there we go. Yeah. But I'm telling you,
I bought, attended when I first got to, I mean,
I've been in a hundred million bars. The only time I felt that that feeling,
it was almost genetics was in that bar with him. Remember in Dublin? Yeah.
We walked in and I was like, Oh, cause they cheese sandwiches,
just plain cheese sandwiches. There was a rug. Like everybody's hanging out.
And.
Those Irish guys, they look like they had like IRA guys.
They were just sitting down with, uh, you know, like the pork salt. Yeah.
And you two used to go there and drink their Bano.
Cause they were Irish bars and parks up. There was some old,
Irish was some Italian boys and then it was just kid bars.
And then it was hippie bars. And then it was like, [inaudible] bars, you know.
As far as surf brunch like they do now. No, no, but salad bar. I remember that.
I used to hit that side.
My PA we used to go eat dinner at Moonies and there was a salad bar,
but it's all gone now. What is the Lululemon store now? What is it now?
This is like a Italian pizza place. Now what counties is. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. See,
I, I, I'm not familiar with that park slope at all yet. Well,
I wish I was park slate.
It's fascinating because of what concepts is so diverse around the time I
grew up, it must be at some point like in that like eighties or nineties,
it must've been like one of the most diverse neighborhoods in the world.
And even, and also socioeconomically diverse,
which is like unique because you go one block that way you were in a totally
different socioeconomic brag. When I was growing up,
it was like sixth Avenue was the cutoff line. Right.
You went down to fifth and you were like, what are you doing?
And now fifth is the hot, hot oppose hope. Now seventh Avenue is deserted.
Yeah. There's nobody. Even on the weekends. There's nobody on the street.
Fifth Avenue, seventh Avenue was hopping and fifth Avenue is hopping. Yeah.
It used to be the absolute reverse, like seventh Avenue was like,
and then it changed because when I was a kid, like all my block, we had the,
we had the, um, McCormick's the horns. I mean, it was all retired.
I wish cops and uh, Gargano's Italians. I mean,
everyone was sitting out on lawn chairs, we just play stoop ball. And uh,
and yeah. And like my, and then like, and then like the,
I think they were like park slope was like the first gentrified neighborhood by.
People who grew up by people by parents.
To grow up in New York.
And like other areas did something well or were ultra liberal hippies and then
moved to park slope. And they were like the progress.
They were like the first like woke kids.
Like those parents were like the first like, Hey, try. You know? And then like,
so they were mixed in with sort of like the Irish, well, I was going to say,
but what about like the old school cops? Even,
they were like more liberal woke cops. I was young when they were kind of like,
that was towards the end of that. Right.
And even everybody was more,
not so much if you wasn't, it was just, everybody was so mixed in,
right. That it was like a lot of people, like all the Italian guys,
like Carol street and all those guys, they were like serious people out of that.
But they would talk to black and Puerto Rican. Like there was sort of a mix,
even though it was, you know,
things could happen and everybody would know exactly where they stood,
but it was still people conversed or people would play ball together.
It was just a very, there was a very fluid line. There was, you know,
avenues and houses live next door to each other. So it wasn't like a,
it wasn't a very segregated.
Yeah, no, it wasn't segregated. You saw each other,
you kind of intermingled on basketball courts on corn. People knew each other.
It was very diverse. You think you're like, you know, smart and well-spoken,
and well-read now because of park slope, both of you guys,
because in my neighborhood, in Ridgewood, I mean, Patty fly balls, the kid just,
you know, he doesn't, we don't think like that. No. I think he,
parks slope has a lot to do with it. It was so much at such an early age.
And like, yeah, that was the people who moved to park slope that was in the air.
That was the energy. It was intellectual.
And it's kind of like progressive thing.
There's the St. Patrick's day parade in park slope. You're right. It's the,
it's the biggest maybe. Is there one in Queens as it still go on?
Can we use that phrase? I remember it like my whole life,
because it would come down prospect park West,
and I grew up between eighth and the park and we'd all run up and watch it.
The bagpipe,
something about bagpipes makes you just want to kill English people.
It's just what it is. Feel it in your bow, like something about it,
shakes your bones. And, uh,
it was the first one you did the short one, the long story short.
It was so good.
But I remember I was sitting in the front and like cherry lane theater. I was,
I was hoping I was like, he knows who. I think he knows who I am.
I think he's looking at me, but you probably wouldn't. It was, it was so good.
It was when you, you, it was like on Broadway or like, bro,
I went and saw it there live, and then we saw it again when it was, uh,
you know, on, was it on HBO after that? Yeah. Yeah.
But that was the first of this new thing that you started,
you found that you were like, this is, you were able to.
What you guys are doing. It's the same thing.
History people act like with toy history, we're talking about today.
It's history. It's the same thing. Right, right, right.
Well, but even, but that's always been calling saw if you watch his HBO special,
I'm the first one where he's wearing the pirates jacket and I have a mullet and
he saying, he's got a model. The kid was a kid was a skinny kid, skinny kid.
He said he got punched through back then. It's good. It was a good look at kids.
It's skinny kids, a little thing called cocaine. Um, and so, no, I'm kidding.
I'm just kidding. So, so, so it's like, uh, so,
but even his style that even on where he sat on the stage and got off and it
wasn't history, but it was that style is unique to Collin. You know what I mean?
No, but that was much tries to do it now. It's not funny.
What's that sitting in that Hannah Gatsby trucks do it. It's just everywhere.
Just calls her to net. Yeah. She's the next one. That's going to write a review,
a positive review about us too, by the way.
She'll never be haunted by Hannah Gatsby.
Just the truth is I could just say quarter by Hannah Gatsby and put a picture of
honest his face and it looks like enough, like kind of gasping. What were you?
What's your favorite ones? My favorite are. I love them all,
but my favorite is New York story. And uh, and, and the,
the first month long story short. Yeah. I love the way it ends in the car.
It's like, you know, my fallback is how favorite. My New York story.
One was to me that when I was heading an ambulance with a heart attack and I
thought I was dying, I was losing breath. Uh, what do you call that?
Respirating? What do you call it? A cardiac arrest. When you, when you start,
your breathing starts getting lower and lower. What's a medical term. Um,
dying shallow breath. Uh, but then there's that respirate I dunno,
I was literally like this and I was like, at least I got New York story out.
Wow. Really? Wow. That's how much I love New York,
because the way we all grew, I mean, you know, New York,
what it meant and to be able to say, Hey, guess what? This is not crazy.
This is that racist.
Oh, shallow breath is how we grew up. Yeah. Like that was so.
For some reason, that meant more to me than any of it. You know what I mean?
Yeah.
So you really thought that when you were laying there and I wrote about that and
here I am with celebrating with turbo Paul.
So we're celebrating this beautiful New York vibe and Chris is
looking up.
I can't handle it. No, no, no,
no, no, no.
Zico. He's like, I'm the medical guy.
He looked at me for the answer and I didn't have it yet. I'm going to get it.
Yeah. You're going to get it.
Which I could have done. No, but you know, check,
check the tape. I said this up, nobody listened. You guys were talking about.
And then I just had to fact check it. And I was
[inaudible] Mike, you heard me say Despina before I busted out the phone,
but they were too busy talking about college,
heart attack to realize what a true genius I am.
Wrap up for all of us. For loving New York. Yeah.
And instead it's about Despina.
Yeah. Christie, the speeding the kid. I mean,
he was talking about like the thoughts about the special he shot on his he's on
his death bed and you're gone, like I'm on dating apps Googling because I'm.
Yeah. Yeah. He's on web MD. Yeah.
So let's get it. So Colin is, he's in the ambulance, he's dying.
And he thinks in New York story.
You'll show because I was like the love, the beauty of like,
you draw the magic and just that everything was, you know,
intertwined in that way. And it's gone now.
It's just this thing where there's so many rules and regulations to what's
appropriate and it just, yeah, it's dead. And I knew it last year,
my friend was, was he he's he does mold inspections.
So he's out in Bedford-Stuyvesant and I get a call from his phone and it's a
lady in East, New York, actually East New York, Brownsville,
East New York lady calls me up black lady. It's like, Hey, um, did you,
uh, this phone, I see this number on the phone.
Some guy left his phone and I'm like, Oh, that's my friend. You're right.
And she goes, yeah. I mean, is he, is, is he a white guy? I'm sorry,
but there was a white guy here earlier. And I was like,
this lady from Brownsville going, I'm sorry. It was your white guy. I was like,
if she's worried about being politically correct. He was somebody who favor,
you got to find that phone in Brownsville. It's over.
Good part. You think there's any positivity to it?
Do you think it's like the world's a better place or people trying to do good.
It's all bad.
Well, I mean, I don't see the good part. I mean, you know, I think that, uh,
I think it's just phony. Well, it's just, there's something about it.
That's just when you're not able to describe certain things it's fake,
you know what I mean? Yeah. It's just,
there's something about it that just rubs me, my gut,
my gut instinct is that it's wrong, you know?
Yeah. Thank you guys for watching. Don't forget to subscribe.
Also turn on alerts more to come tell frown. Absolutely.
And go to patrion.com/bay, rich boys to join the matriarch or with things.
Yeah.